bonsoir dr weiss bon sens patrice vous
allez bien oui revient tout va bien on
continue
dr je vous montre un petit tableau très
rapide c'est le taux d'occupation des
lits à montréal laval montérégie on voit
que quand monsieur legault dit que c
'est ristat ce qui fait référence là on
peut pas se permettre et vous à votre
hôpital comme dans les autres dans la
grande région de montréal de recevoir
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
de malades la coved ou ce report du
déconfinement à montréal d'une semaine
en réalité il ya plusieurs points qu'il
faut que leur déconfinement montréal
doit être reportée d'abord il ya le fait
que l'épidémie n'est pas maîtrisé dans
les ch et celle des les centres de soins
prolongés
l'épidémie n'est pas remis de crise et
dans la communauté le nombre de cas
continue d'augmenter
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup plus de cas
que ce contest parce qu'on ne teste pas
tout le monde il ya eu un certain nombre
d'hôpitaux qui ont été touchés par des
éclosions important qui fait que ces
hôpitaux là sont je vous dirais
difficilement capable de prendre des
augmentations importantes de volume mais
surtout de revenir à une activité entre
guillemets un peu plus normale où on va
devoir venir de toutes les façons et
donc et il ya aussi la capacité de
tester qui doit augmenter de façon
relativement rapidement et deux derniers
points c'est qu'on n'a toujours pas
réglé au québec
notre problème d'accès à des équipements
de protection personnelle entre autres
au niveau par exemple des masses et même
si on reçoit des masses ici et là c'est
toujours un petit peu compliqué et là on
devrait aussi se poser la question est
ce qu'on pourrait un jour fabriquer des
masques au québec dans votre province
canadienne pour pouvoir devenir plus
indépendant par rapport à lallaing la
fourniture à l'extérieur du pays donc il
ya un ensemble de facteurs qui fait que
d'emmener dans une situation très
fragilisé sur l'île de montréal et même
autour la rive-nord la rive-sud un petit
peu qui fait que c est difficile
actuellement de se lancer dans un des
continents massis au cas où il y aurait
une augmentation et une résurgence de
parce que réexpliquer new kids id
confirme
dix nouveaux cas c'est à peu près une
certitude là certainement l'idée je
voulais déjà dit c'est que finalement on
accepte d'avoir un certain nombre de
nouveaux cas pour essayer de
tranquillement à voir au lieu d'avoir
cent mille cas on va dire sur un bois
l'objectif c'est peut-être d'en avoir
dix mille mais sur dix mois j'exagère un
peu c'est pour faire une image
mais l'objectif est d'avoir des nombres
de cas en plus petites quantités sur une
plus longue période de temps
donc c'est surtout quand les enfants
retournent à l'école on n'ouvre plus de
commerces les gens sont plus dans la rue
et ainsi de suite
il y aura plus de contamination mais si
on est capable d'avoir on est capable de
gérer cette augmentation cet afflux de
nouveaux patients sans avoir un système
qui est débordée et noyer c'est gérable
et faisable et c'est même bien jusqu'à
un certain point
par contre un moment donné si la vague
qui va ce prêt qui va foncer vers nous
et beaucoup plus grosse que ce qu'on
pensait avoir et à cause de tout ce que
je vous ai dit en termes d'équipement de
préparation et c'est là on risque de se
retrouver dans un autre problème et on
verra dans deux semaines passaient pas
c'est pas un absolu non plus on pourrait
devoir reporter
tant que la situation n'est pas
contrôlée tank qui a pas une vraiment
une bonne marge dans les hôpitaux
très bien alors à suivre j'ai quelques
questions pour vous ou si un virus est
habituellement tendance à perdre de sa
virulence en mutins ayant ce transfert
mais tant de personne à personne comme
le h1n1 et le strass par exemple la
coved 19 pourrait-elle connaître le même
sort de menton alors en réalité non un
virus ne mute en a pas vraiment devenir
moins dangereux il peut même à
l'occasion de venir plus dangereux que
de venir le plus résistant par contre ce
qui va arriver c'est qu'il ya une espèce
on va dit on va apprendre à apprivoiser
le virus et le virus va apprivoiser
l'espèce humaine donc avec le temps il
va y avoir un moment donné une espèce de
jeu vous dirait de connaissance du virus
de notre part et de virus va être
peut-être moins virulent pour devenir
encore je dirais plus facile à
transmettre d'un individu à l'autre
parce que rappelez vous
souvent plus les virus sont faciles à se
transmettre dans le simple rhume et
moins ils sont dangereux pluies sont
difficiles à se transmettre plus ils ont
tendance à être dangereux pour une
raison très simple un virus a besoin
d'un d'une machine de nos cellules pour
se multiplier
s'ils se mettaient à tuer tout le monde
il commettrait un suicide il aurait plus
personne à qui infecte et et se
multiplier donc c'est un espèce
d'équilibré donc mutation veut pas
forcément dire moins virulent ou plus
virulents ça peut vouloir dire les deux
mais il n'y a pas de règle absolue il
nous paralyse pas à peu près mais peut
pas nous tuer tout le monde parce qu'il
n'aurait plus lui-même n'existerait plus
sans zoom 20x exactement il faut un
autre virus le virus il faut savoir que
pour se multiplier si on prenait tous
les virus sont les mettez sur une table
il se passer absolument rien il finirait
par mourir et donc ils finiraient leur
vie pourrait pas se répliquer à les
infecter d'autres personnes donc à un
moment donné il faut qu'ils trouvent des
clients entre guillemets a infecté pour
pouvoir se multiplier et ensuite pour
pouvoir cet individu là puisse donner le
virus a offert ce alors je passe à la
question 3 donc je suis âgé de plus de
70 ans et ma génération a reçu très peu
de vaccins comparativement plus jeunes
est ce que ça pourrait être un facteur
qui influence la gravité du virus chez
les personnes plus âgées
non alors la première chose c'est pas
pourri c'est vrai qu'ils ont reçu
peut-être un peu moins de vaccins mais
des gens qui ont 70 ans au québec
aujourd'hui ont quand même reçu
relativement pas mal de max entre autres
même dans les années 50 que la polio et
ses terrains et donc ça c'est la
première chose et puis souvent ces gens
là commence à recevoir plus de vaccin
contre la pneumonie à pneumocoque contre
le zona etc
mais il n'y a pas de lien entre le fait
d'avoir reçu moins de vaccins et d'être
moins protégés parce que les vaccins
sont très souvent spécifiques à un micro
une bactérie un virus
donc si je vous donne un vaccin pour
vous protéger contre l'influenza ça vous
protège pas contre le coronavirus et
vice versa si vous avez un vaccin contre
la méningite ça pas vraiment d'impact
pour les coronavirus donc le fait
d'avoir reçu beaucoup un peu de vaccin
n'a pas vraiment de lien c'est vraiment
l'âge qui est le dire et le facteur
marqué deux
la sévérité de la maladie et même si on
est en forme on en a souvent parlé
ensemble parce qu'on a eu beaucoup de
courriels de gens qu'ils se disent moi
je cours un marathon l'autre vous
souvenez cet homme qui monte est un
volcan en afrique j'ai pas trop et en os
même si on est en forme on n'est plus un
risque plus on est âgé
oui tout simplement c'est sûr si vous
êtes en forme et âgés ben tant mieux
vous avez peut-être moins de risque de
mourir ou d'avoir des complications mais
si vous êtes nous avait 75 ans en super
forme
peu importe la forme que vous avez vous
êtes d'emblée plus à risque que
quelqu'un qui en a 35 et en forme aussi
alors c'est malheureusement c'est la
nature de la biologie humaine et ne
lavent du processus de vieillissement
des cellules humaines
on n'y échappe pas deux très rapides
qu'elles sont aussi plusieurs membres
d'une même famille sont infectés est ce
qu'il reste de ce surinfectée en se
côtoyant au quotidien non pas vraiment
et ce qui risque de faire ces gosses le
transmettre l'un à l'autre mais c'est
pas parce qu'un arrêt qui est infecté le
deuxième est infecté à ce moment là le
troisième il sera pas plus affecté parce
qu'on a deux qui sont infectés il va
tout simplement être en contact plus
souvent avec le virus et s'il ne fait
rien on ne fait rien bah c'est
probablement encore tant mieux pour
cette personne ça se peut qu'elle était
infectée qu'elle a développé des
anticorps on le saura au moment où on
fera de sérologie marguerite six ans
vous demande ma maman m'a dit que le
purell ne lave pas les mains
c'est beaucoup mieux de l'eau et du
savon pendant 20 secondes après la
récréation pour enlever tous les micros
mais la saleté est ce vrai devant
marguerite
bon alors là la réponse il faut toujours
écouter sa maman donc oui en réalité
l'eau et le savon c'est très très bon
c'est quelque chose de très efficace
mais le purell aussi ça marche la seule
chose c'est quand on a accès à de l'eau
et du savon
c'est mieux d'utiliser de l'eau et du
savon mais quand on n'a pas ces ados et
du savon le purell c'est efficace et
j'aime pas dire le purell parce que ce
sont des jeunes alcoolisés
c'est une marque de clubs aimeraient
apprendre utilisent des jeunes
alcoolisés a donc à ce moment là c'est
efficace mais c'est un remplacement à
l'eau et au savon qui est facilement
disponible quand on peut y avoir
dr weiss merci beaucoup à très bientôt
bonne soirée